sekiro is an excellent game then it only
has a wonderful story but also a unique
approach to its storytelling that hasn't
been seen in the soul series before it's
a game that was an enjoyable experience
throughout every moment i played and i
cannot recommend it enough as always
welcome back to another story review the
series where i not only discuss the
game's story but also critique it along
the way today's episode is going to be
on sekiro with many more souls games to
come in the near future if you do want
to see some more souls content you can
also watch my bloodborne video that i
published about a month ago but with
that out of the way let's get started so
to no one's surprise sakura like other
souls game starts with a cut scene that
sets the background for the story sekiro
takes place in japan during the sengoku
era we also learned that there was a
rebellion that was started which
ultimately led to a victory thanks to a
soldier named ishin ashina who was
responsible for slaying the opposing
faction's leader general tamura after
the battle of shinobi by the name of owl
discovers a child sitting around dozens
of bodies and decides to welcome the
child into his home he then trains this
young boy in the way of the sword as
well as the iron code which is that the
father's word is absolute and the
master's word being second in priority
through years of training and hardship
this child would become a full-fledged
shinobi and our protagonist known as
wolf but something went wrong both owl
and his master are gone so with no
purpose in his life he now just sits at
the bottom of a well waiting for a
purpose or death whatever comes first
however one day he receives a note that
leads him to the moonlight tower and
when wolf arrives at said tower he finds
lord kuro who is not only the divine
heir but also his master kuro needs some
assistance he wants to escape ashina as
the never ending war that has plagued
japan is slowly making its way back to
ashina castle and kurl wants to leave
and run away from what he calls the
faded bloodline the two take a secret
passage but are caught by ghanichiro
ashino the adopted grandson of ishin
ashina geniciro wants kuro it's unclear
why but he needs him for his plan and
won't let us escape so we fight and
being the skilled shinobi that we are we
have no problem getting absolutely
destroyed by him kinichiro cuts off
wolf's arm who then collapsed from blood
loss while gennichiro takes kuro away
somehow though wolf was able to survive
thanks to an old man named the sculptor
who was not only able to nurse him back
to health but also give him a prosthetic
wooden arm to replace our recently cut
off one from the sculptor we learned one
thing kinichiro plans to use kuro's
bloodline for something and we need to
get him back thus setting the game's
plot in motion so already this is a
fantastic start and this intro
highlights many unique design decisions
within sekiro firstly it took six games
what we now finally have a named and
voice protagonist sekuro still retains
that soul's formula of giving the player
a title like ashen 1 or hunter as in
this game were referred to as the
shinobi of the divine air but most
characters will still call him wolf
furthermore it's evident right from the
beginning that this game has a very
unique style to its storytelling sekiro
is a very cutscene and dialogue driven
game seguro has a lot of cutscenes and
conversations especially in the very
beginning and many of the game's
objectives can be completed without
talking to npcs as opposed to other
games where npcs were just optional the
story is also quite linear and this ties
into the npcs as well as many characters
will repeat quest objectives about four
to five times then a couple minutes to
make sure the player knows what they're
doing and will also have to report back
to these npcs once the objectives are
completed the souls games also love to
draw inspiration from specific media and
bloodborne took this a step further by
making hp lovecraft and his lovecraftian
stories be the inspiration for the
game's plot and while sekiro does do
this as well instead of fully embracing
the fictional elements of h.p lovecraft
like with bloodborne sekibro goes in the
opposite direction and instead focuses
on non-fiction storytelling by using
history culture and religion all of
these decisions are very bold especially
coming from a game series that likes to
stick to what it knows best this further
added to the attraction of the game as
this was something the soul series has
never done before however one of these
decisions being the history and culture
surrounding the game will become an
issue to explain why we need to recap
that intro again with the proper context
as i said this game takes place in the
sengoku era of japan which was a real
time period in japan's history it was an
over 100 year conflict that started
because the shogunate at the time was
losing influence this then caused many
of the local lords to vie for power and
attempt to dismantle all the other lords
and even overtake the shogunate the main
purpose was to eventually unify all of
japan under one rule and after the final
battle called the siege of osaka japan
was eventually unified under the rule of
tokugawa iyasu relating this back to
sekura that's why the first line in the
game japan was consumed by a perpetual
conflict makes sense as that matches
with the current time period the sengoku
era more transpires then it also brings
context to what's going on in the game
japan is still under siege and judging
from the use of guns and the lore of
ashina it seems that we're entering the
final years of the conflict that means
ashina castle is either one of or the
only place left now fully unified under
japan the question though is how is this
possible well one of these reasons is
integral to the main plot which is
immortality but we'll circle back to
that later as the other reason was ishin
ashuna is already incredibly strong
because of its generals but ishim was on
a whole nother level considering the
fact that ishan is probably in his 70s
or 80s in a profession with a very low
survival rate the fact that he is alive
at all is quite terrifying especially
when you consider that because wolfe was
a child during this battle eeshan has to
be around 50 years old and was able to
single-handedly take down the enemy
factions general so obviously it's quite
clear that sekiro decided to utilize a
very important time period in japan's
history as the backdrop for its story
and while i do like this approach there
is an issue because of the history of
this game it can be very hard to
understand what it's trying to say
sekuro is a japanese game made by a
japanese developer and since the game
contains material they're familiar with
they're free to go as in depth as
possible to create an accurate story and
while that's great for the japanese
audience this can confuse and damper a
bit of the experience for everyone else
however while i did call this an issue
it's really hard to complain about this
decision as it's not really something
you can say is inherently bad more just
unfortunate playing sekuro and trying to
connect this game to japan's history is
like a japanese audience playing
assassin's creed 3 and connecting that
game to america's history the games are
fine on their own but the problem of
course is when one group tries to play
the other for an example we can take the
cherry blossom trees in japan the ones
with the pink petals this tree
represents new beginnings good fortune
and revival which is why these pink
petals appear when we revive in game
without looking into this information
you could just assume that they were
just visual effects without any real
meaning but within their culture there's
a reason for this just like i said
before on its own it's not a big deal
but it can be quite troublesome when you
have to juggle the meaning of the cherry
blossom trees along with all the other
references like why the devs chose to
have giant snakes and dragons be these
large creatures as opposed to any other
animal why this game has a fascination
with centipedes and even just the basic
ideas of buddhism to understand every
single detail and reference in secure
you will need to have lots of extensive
knowledge outside of the game but as
someone who doesn't i can say with
certainty that the only real info you
need to learn is the history i
summarized regarding the sengoku period
everything else is nice and definitely
really interesting to look into if
you're passionate about the history of
japan and how it ties into sekiro but i
don't think it's necessary to understand
the story this game is really trying to
tell as we discussed earlier our
objective is to rescue the divine air
from ghanichiro the problem is that he's
all the way at the top of ashina castle
and while the journey to goodkuro was
very engaging thanks to the combat for
the purposes of this video it does get a
little boring sekiro like many games has
certain parts where the gameplay is at
the forefront this because the game is
trying to familiarize us with stealth
grapple posture and deflect mechanics
that make up the core combat so because
of this the story takes a backseat for a
bit so we can understand these mechanics
it's not an issue and it's something i
never complain about it just makes it
discussing the story of the game a bit
difficult when the next five to six
hours we don't make a whole lot of
progress so before we get to the castle
let's take a step back and talk about
the game itself sekiro is a very
gorgeous game and the level design and
exploration is quite linear compared to
other souls games as while some areas do
connect to one another it's not as
intricate as the souls trilogy with its
shortcuts and branching pathways however
i still firmly believe the intention of
this game was to create a different take
on the gameplay and storytelling so i
don't mind its linearity and even if
that wasn't the intended purpose a game
being linear doesn't make it bad
insecure just goes to show that a souls
game can be very linear and still
provide an enjoyable experience it's
during this exploration although we are
introduced to our base of operations as
well as some npcs that we'll be meeting
quite a bit the dilapidated temple is
definitely one of my favorite locations
because i love the area's seclusion and
also how it fits into the world very
seamlessly the past souls games did this
very well with the firelink shrine from
dark souls 1 being a highlight but
recently the series has started delving
into this idea that the base of
operation should be separate from the
main content like the hunter's dream or
the round table hold in secure though
instead of teleporting for the base of
operations to a spot on the map you
could just simply walk out the front
gate and start exploring it's a small
detail but i really enjoyed that about
the dilapidated temple within the temple
are three npcs that we'll get to know
throughout the game who are the sculptor
the man who saved us and is responsible
for creating and upgrading our
prosthetic tool emma who's a doctor that
serves under lord eshin and will also
upgrade our gourd and hanbe who is a
target dummy who can't die due to some
form of immortality minus the three of
the dilapidated temple and some of the
others that are more related to the
story the game also has some optional
npcs we can talk to but it's definitely
not one of sakura's strong suits a lot
of the optional npcs seem to only be
placed in the world for one specific
reason like this one dying soldier who
warns us of the enemy ahead or this monk
who found his way into the halls of
illusion and has no plans of leaving
that's literally their entire character
probably the only interesting npc in
this game is jin zaimon this random
warrior that patrols the outskirts of
ashina who is entranced by some music
that he can only hear we end up
following him throughout the game until
we find him gravely injured near this
apparition called lady oren she asked us
about this lord sakuza and if we've seen
him before and seeing as we have no clue
who that is we tell her no but she gets
angry and claims that we're lying to her
after defeating orrin it seems like her
mind has gained some sort of clarity as
she seems happy to die she can now be
with lord sakuza implying that this
sakuza along with her are both dead but
the reason she's still here is because
her spirit couldn't pass on so we kind
of help her continue into the afterlife
once we talk with josemon again he gives
us a gizzo statue and from this dialogue
in the item description it seems to
imply that he was related to obren and
sakuza and was possibly the couple's son
apparently this may also be related to a
popular japanese ghost story which once
again further adds to the beauty of this
questline jin zaiman is one of the few
npcs in this game with an actual quest
line and is by far the best at it
another npc that i definitely took a
liking to was koturo but not because of
a quest line but more just because he's
a really sweet kid and it's kind of hard
to hate him but while jazeemon's quest
was great it was a little bittersweet as
it makes me wish that they could apply
this same effort to other characters and
not have this overabundance of npcs and
merchants that don't really say anything
but one line getting back to the story
while progressing through the ashina
outskirts you may stumble upon these
ghost figures which are actually just
remnants of lord kuro this remnant is
specifically important as it's a
conversation between ghanichiro and kuro
who talks about the inner ministry and
how they were able to drive them back
once but their army is too powerful this
is why ganichiro wants kuro because he
knows that ashina can be defended by
normal means but what does he mean by
this well lord koro is part of a divine
lineage that is related to the divine
dragon and this lineage gives curl the
power of the dragon's heritage which is
immortality this is why gennichiro wants
kuro he wants to gain the power of the
dragon's heritage through lord korros
that he can be immortal and prevent
ashina from being taken over this not
only gives us a hint of the events to
come as it briefly mentions the interior
ministry but also lets us learn a bit
more about ganichiro we'll end up seeing
more of him later but kenichiro might be
my favorite character in this whole game
as his backstory and motivation fit so
well together according to some item
descriptions related to gedichiro we
discover that he was taken in by ashino
when his mother died so he's extremely
grateful for the people that live here
so much so that he sees them as his
extended family so when the country of
his people is under attack he'll do
anything he can to save them even if it
means using heretical arts the
description is both cryptic and
informative as it shows that he's
willing to go as far as possible to
defend ashuna but we don't know what
those heretical arts are this is also
probably a good time to mention the item
descriptions as just like previous games
some of sekiro's lore is discovered via
item descriptions main bosses will drop
memories which when consumed for attack
power turn into remnants the remnants
are where the heart of the stories are
and while for some they don't provide
too much information for most of the
bosses it's definitely enough to get an
idea of who they were thanks to its
accessible story and access to the
remnants you can get a large amount of
the story just from these two sources
and it continues to reinforce that this
difference in storytelling was a bold
but fantastic choice right next to the
remnant of ghanichiro and kuro is a
large battlefield which also happens to
be the arena for the first boss kiyobu
masataka oniwa i never mentioned this
before but sakiro can be played in
japanese with english subtitles this is
similar to ghost of tsushima which i
believe also has the same feature in the
rare case that a game will offer me this
option i usually take the original
language as i feel it's authentic as i
normally have subtitles on anyway but if
there was ever a reason to play this
game in english it's this intro
my name
is
as i breathe
you will not pass the castle gate it is
so over the top and absurd that i
couldn't help but laugh and it kind of
speaks to gyobu's character gilbert was
a leader of a group of bandits but when
they came face to face with ishin they
were easily defeated however during
their fight isha noticed his
determination and skill so he would
decide to take him in as an oshino
warrior gyoba really values strength
over everything and that's why he has
this aggressive demeanor when he attacks
us because he knows he's powerful and he
can portray that to us interestingly
enough the spear that he uses also seems
to be the same spirit that general
tamura used during his battle with ishin
which is quite poetic and that also
brings up a good point and it's
something i really appreciate about this
game and it's how wonderful and detailed
the presentation is a good example is
the minor details that occur throughout
the game such as tomorrow's spear which
is used by giobu and then will
eventually be used by ishin later in the
game furthermore when we challenge
ganichiro again we're able to see wolf's
growth as a shinobi as he pulls out the
sword with ease whereas in the intro we
can see him fumbling with the hilt there
are also the similar circumstances
between the sculptor and wolf who were
both fighters that had their arms
removed the sculptor had his removed by
ishin whereas wolf had his removed by
ganichiro we have two unrelated people
who became a team cutting off the limbs
of two unrelated people who became a
team
interesting this even extends to the
cutscenes before the fights especially
the one with kinichiro again which takes
place in this beautiful land of flowers
and the camera angle specifically
positions him to the side so the full
length of his sword along with the moon
is shown in the scene speaking of
genitiro we can now talk about his boss
fight after defeating gyobu and the
blazing bull you're presented with this
tower along with numerous other
buildings attached to it this is the
heart of ashina castle and gonichu
always at the top assuming you make it
to the top you'll be greeted by emma
kuro and geniciro he's still trying to
get kiro's powers but he won't budge
that's when we step in and attempt to
save him i like the stakes of this fight
as not only is it a rematch between
wolfe and geniciro it's a rematch
between him and us we finally get to get
payback for him cutting off our arm but
ganichibro came prepared he's still a
competent fighter and could definitely
be the first wall players will run into
but just when you think you've finally
beaten him kidichiro proves that he's
willing to do whatever it takes to save
ashina and fights using the way of
tomaway which means he's going to throw
lightning at us thankfully we learned a
lightning reversal just before this
fight and can send it back to him but
i'd be lying if i told you i wasn't
shocked when this happened one thing i
noticed as well was the black marks on
his body you could just play these off
as wounds but i think these are from the
lightning powers of his as maybe it's
trying to convey that geniciro harmed
himself when attempting to control
lightning for the first time regardless
it's a nice detail but what's even
better is the name the way of tomaway
tomo is an unknown character at this
point in time and we'll talk about her a
bit later towards the end but i really
love how they connected her in geniciro
as tomoe was his master and he learned
the lightning attacks from her which is
interesting as the only other people
able to conjure lightning in this game
are the okami women at the fountainhead
palace plus they can also do a move
called the floating passage which is a
skill that we can learn which is also
the same move that kenichiro does to us
meaning he was trained by tomoe who's an
okami woman as i said it doesn't mean
much now but once we learn a bit more
about them you'll come to appreciate the
parallels between them and how well this
was conveyed to us it's similar to how
bloodborne had to rely on context clues
in the environment to convey certain
parts of the story such as the backstory
of the one reborn being connected to
yahar ghoul and i really love how this
was integrated again eventually though
we will defeat genitro and rescue kiro
but he's still not done for now he
leaves but not only will we see him
again later the way of tomawe wasn't
even close to his full arsenal as that
resurrection is a part of his next
surprise the rejuvenating waters i think
it's been long enough so let's talk
about the elephant in the room that
being this game's obsession with
immortality bulkadichiro and kuro are
immortal but there are two others that
we know about that being hanbe and wolf
who are also immortal resurrecting isn't
just a gameplay mechanic it's a genuine
part of the story their various
different forms of immortality or more
accurately for some of them body
altering methods within sakura the first
is the dragon's heritage which is
created with someone of divine blood
like lord koro he also has the power to
give people immortality to what's called
the immortal oath that's why we're able
to live because kuro gave wolf his blood
during the hirata estate attack
something i'll mention later this is the
purest form of immortality because it
comes from the divine dragon and is very
easy to acquire but it comes at a price
if someone has the dragon's heritage
their blood stagnates says they can
never die however should someone with
the dragon's heritage die enough times
then that blood overflows and creates a
disease called dragon rot remember you
can still die with the dragon's heritage
inside you but you can't fully die you
just resurrect soon after when we die
our blood stagnates and if we keep dying
then the disease will spread this dragon
rot disease has a chance of affecting
the npcs throughout the game although to
be honest this never really became an
issue for me as most of the people who
were affected were merchants and yes
while it does have the chance of
completely halting npc quest lines i've
never had this happen but maybe i just
got lucky our next immortality has to do
with the divine child of rejuvenation
she becomes relevant in the story after
the fight with kenichiro but she has
what we can call false dragon's heritage
that's because the monks at the senpo
temple became enthralled by the concept
of immortality so much so that they
devoted every waking minute to try and
perfect it they even attempted to use
children in their experiments to see if
they could create their version of the
dragon's heritage kotaro was the
caretaker for these kids and is sad
because all the kids have left him the
reason they left though is because they
died if these statues and pinwheels are
meant to symbolize each child then a lot
of them have passed away from this in
fact we can meet a parent of the kids
here at the temple
the armored warrior is a european
soldier who came to japan because of
these rejuvenating waters and the
promise of fixing this illness but that
ended up not working across the temple
are these red and white pinwheels that
are for the children who died but
there's one pure white pinwheel that
represents the only survivor of the
experiments who is the divine child of
rejuvenation as i said she's the only
one to have survived and even though
she's happy to be alive she detests the
monks that did this to her and her
friends the child however is in the
inner sanctum an area that is only
accessed once we beat the folding screen
monkeys in the halls of illusion which
according to some item descriptions is a
place that exists between the planes of
life and death implying that this is a
spiritual plane that can only be
accessed by a select few the only ones
able to access this place are kotaro
this random monk and us it's possible
though that if someone is infested they
may not be allowed to enter and by
infested i mean the centipedes we see
everywhere the monks of the sempo temple
and even some other notable enemies like
the guardian ape and the corrupted monk
are seen covered in centipedes and the
centipedes seem to make them immortal we
don't know why but they just do for some
reason but there's a key distinction
between this and kuros power whereas
kuro's power allows one to resurrect the
centipede prevents the host from dying
at all they can never resurrect because
they're never going to die in the first
place there are two books we can find in
the game called the holy chapter
infested and the holy chapter dragon's
return that seemed to infer that the
high priest of sempo temple was blessed
by the centipede and that because it had
become one with him he was able to walk
the path of immortality but he wanted to
find out why however it seems like he
was never able to find an answer what we
can assume though is that the centipede
possibly came from the rejuvenating
waters which could explain their ability
to make their host immortal as the
guardian ape is located near the lotus
of the palace a flower that according to
its description is near the palace
waters and the corrupted monk is
guarding the palace itself which is
obviously surrounded by its water which
then leads us to our final method of
immortality which is the rejuvenating
waters however earlier i said body
altering method not necessarily
immortality because the rejuvenating
waters don't seem to make people
immortal the rejuvenating waters came
from the divine dragon when it entered
the land of japan ages ago it then
expelled this water across the land the
water originally started in a place
called the fountainhead palace but then
would make it eventually to meebu
village currently the theory i have is
that the distance of the water relative
to the source is important as i think
the farther it travels the fewer side
effects occur as within the fountainhead
palace we can find these carp-like
nobles who patrol the area whereas in
meebu village they're still semi-human
we do know that the water started at
fountainhead palace and did make its way
to meebu village but it seems like the
villagers didn't know of its origin and
its side effects as from what we can
gather the town mayor treated the
villagers to tons of sake one night but
when you drink sake you obviously get
really thirsty and since they ran out
they had to resort to drinking water
from the stream but then the side
effects kicked in turning them into
these semi-zombie type humans however
all the inhabitants of both locations
can die when we kill them so it doesn't
seem to make them immortal maybe just
prolong their life or grant them some
resistances the only character who
doesn't fit into this equation is
ghanichiro as he clearly resurrects wolf
even says it himself confirming that we
did kill ganichiro at this point but the
waters brought him back to life so how
is this possible rejuvenating sediment
that's what we call a particularly
concentrated part of the rejuvenating
waters i'm sure you saw it for yourself
the rejuvenating sediment grants great
resilience in one's flesh one becomes
able to withstand blows that would be
fatal to anyone else so it seems that
kinichiro consumed the rejuvenating
sediment instead of the rejuvenating
waters which is why he reacted to it
differently than those at meebo village
so as a recap we have the purest form of
immortality that being the dragon's
heritage within kuro the unexpected
immortality of the centipedes the child
of rejuvenation who was created as a way
for the sempo temple to make a false
dragon's heritage and then the
rejuvenating waters and sediment that
seemed to grant resistances and possibly
a prolonged life when ingested so the
next question you might be asking is why
is this important well once again it all
leads back to lord karo pearl being the
divine heir with the dragon's heritage
wants to sever his ties to his
immortality has he seen the effects it
has on people and does not wish for this
power to be used by anyone remember when
the story used to be about rescuing a
child well now it's about immortality
this is very similar to bloodborne
storytelling where it hides the true
story until the halfway point of the
game i think bloodborne did this much
better as that was intended to be a
major plot twist but i can't deny that
sakura has succeeded quite well in doing
the same as i said earlier sakura's
story is very simple save lord kuro then
sever his ties of immortality but when
you jump down the rabbit hole of sakura
you realize just how deep it truly goes
and that without a doubt definitely
deserves some recognition so we have our
new goal but where do we start we'll do
some dialogue with both kuro and emma we
discover what items we specifically need
these items also tie into the game's
endings which i really liked as for once
i knew what the items were why they were
important and what ending they are
required for which made me even more
invested in the story while some of
these items are only for specific
endings each one of them requires two
necessary items that being the mortal
blade and the divine dragon tears the
mortal blade can be given to us by the
child of rejuvenation who claims that
everyone who's picked up this weapon has
died which is not an issue because we
can't die the mortal blade is important
as the actual blade itself can kill
those who cannot die meaning we can
sever kuro's immortality however if
you're puzzled by that description then
you and emma have caught on to kuros's
plan wolff is extremely loyal to kiro
and without him he would have no purpose
so if he were to tell wolfe to sever his
ties by killing him he probably wouldn't
go through with it so emma and wolf
devise a plan and try to prevent this
from happening however this isn't good
news either emma talks with the sculptor
and also finds some notes written by
tomaway the girl we talked about earlier
and discovers that to sever the ties of
immortality while keeping the master
alive the one who has the blood must die
so now we're at a crossroads we either
sever the ties of immortality by killing
kuro obviously not a good choice or we
kill ourselves and allow kuro to live
also not a good choice but there is a
third option through some discussion
with the divine child of rejuvenation we
discovered that it's possible to sever
the ties of immortality by sending the
divine dragon back to where it came from
allowing both kuro and wolf to live
while also forcing the dragon to return
home this also ties into the second item
we need which is the divine dragon tears
which are just simply tears from the
divine dragon which is necessary for the
ritual meaning we somehow have to get to
this divine realm so those are our three
options each one requires specific items
for the ritual to work properly so it's
on the player to find these items then
do the ending they want i know it sounds
like we skipped really far ahead in the
story but now that we've hit the halfway
point the game really focuses on the
severance ritual that we must perform
but it's not the entire focus i said
earlier that the remnant of gennichiro
and kuro was a foreshadowing of the
events to come and it's during these
next few hours when wolf scavenges the
land for the required items that this
will occur after returning to ashina
with the shelter stone and one of the
items we need for the ritual we'll
notice that something's wrong all the
fast travel points are gone and by
making our way back to ashino we
discover that these central forces have
started their assault the central forces
are the samurai dressed in red with the
purple soldiers being the most elite
group called the interior ministry
remember sakura takes place at the end
of the sengoku era so it can be assumed
that these central forces are trying to
take over ashinosa that they may unify
japan under their banner and if that
wasn't bad enough an old relative makes
his appearance what are you plotting al
plotting
i would do no such thing
owl has returned and he's here for one
reason kuro see owl's been plotting
something for years and has been using
wolf this entire time i will just like
anichira wants the blood of kuro owl
wants to be immortal in order for him to
do this he'll need a foolproof plan
firstly he needs someone who can get
close to him that someone would be wolf
how was he certain that wolfe was going
to follow him well he saved him from
when he was young and became his father
figure over the years he also instilled
the iron code within wolf something that
he wanted him to live by just in case he
needed to use it as i said before the
iron code states that the father's word
is absolute with the masters being
second so with that in mind it makes
sense why owl wants wolf to follow the
rules of the code so that owl can enact
his plan the question that remains is
where has owl been well very early in
the game you'll be given a bell charm by
an old lady by taking this to the buddha
statue at the temple you can relive a
memory from the harada estate there's
also another bell charm that you can
find that belongs to owl which will also
take us to the harada estate the harada
estate memory was three years in the
past and it allows us to see the events
of a very important time in sekiro's
story except an issue will arise from
both the bells as it's that both of them
showcase the events of the harada estate
but either have wrong information or
it's in the wrong order for example the
end boss of the first memory is a lady
butterfly who we kill but in the second
memory it's owl who we also kill the
second one is clearly wrong as if we
killed owl in the past he wouldn't be
here in the present so to do this
properly we're gonna have to jump
between both memories to get the real
truth so three years ago wolfe was sent
out on some mission it's unclear by who
but we can assume it was owl when wolf
returns he finds the estate in flames
apparently some bandits took it upon
themselves to burn the estate down kill
the villagers and robbed the place clean
the reason this attack worked so well is
because many of the estate's guards were
out fighting the wars happening near
ashino the timing of this attack seems
too perfect and some of the villagers
think so as well you were nowhere to be
seen when things went south
wait tell me you didn't lead them here
yourself the timing of their attack was
perfect
normally those bandits wouldn't have
stood a chance yes
yes it had to be you i hope you die
traitor i wouldn't go that far but he's
definitely correct though that the
timing was way too perfect wolf's main
goal as the shinobi of the divine air is
to find kuro and make sure he's safe on
the way there though he will encounter
awl who seems to be gravely wounded and
will pass away due to his injuries we
continue on and find lord kuro except
lady butterfly stops us from leaving
this encounter is interesting as lady
butterfly was wolf's mentor so why is
she attacking us my growing theory is
that she's either working with owl or at
the very least betraying ashina before
her boss fight we see this old lady
trembling in fear who happens to be the
same old lady who gives us the bell
further down the hallway is her son
inosuke who we can also find in the
present and apparently was injured and
rendered blind by lady butterfly i can't
imagine inosuke was betraying the ashina
meaning him and lady butterfly should
have been allies so this leads me to
believe that she was betraying the
ashina along with owl now whether or not
they were working together or just had a
common goal is never stated but i also
believe there's an answer to this after
defeating lady butterfly wolf gets
stabbed in the back there is no doubt in
my mind that this was owl which means
that not only was he faking his injuries
it's possible he was injured by lady
butterfly and upon discovering that we
are here at the estate he gives us the
key to the fort where kuro is hiding
with the hope that will fight her if we
win then he gets to stab us if we lose
we'll have to fight her again but given
how much damage we did to her assuming
you actually did damage to her then owl
would have an easier time putting her
down he basically wants us to fight her
and then third party the winner so the
divine error can be his from this
information we can also assume that he
sent us away on a mission so that the
divine air was unguarded as remember the
timing was almost too perfect after
getting stabbed kuro sees wolf dying and
recognizes the bravery he possesses and
gives him his blood this moment is why
wolf can resurrect but that was just one
memory the other memory will tell the
real story we learned from owl's bell
charm that the interior ministry was a
part of the attack as well the first
memory will also provide you with a hint
to the real story as we can fight an
interior ministry soldier in that memory
except there's only one furthermore we
learn from an eavesdrop conversation
between juzo and a soldier from the
ministry that owl was behind the attack
that's why everything worked so well owl
being a shinobi of the ashina would know
the troop movements and knew when to
strike as for why i will join forces
with the ministry it's because i believe
they had aligned goals i will wanted the
divine error and the interior ministry
wanted to defeat the ashina clan and a
huge blow to their forces would be the
hirada estate neither cared about the
other's goals but the two realized that
by attacking the estate together they
could both get what they wanted so they
became allies so now we have to ask how
do the bells work so this involves some
magical elements as it seems that wolfe
is physically in these memories as not
only does he keep his prosthetic after
talking with one of the ashini shinobi
he comments on the attack the dragon
spring pilgrimage
i was three years ago
what is this
the sculptor mentioned an old memory
i don't remember any of this
but it appears this is the past there is
many times throughout the game that this
night gets brought up but wolf seems to
have no memory of this moment this to me
means that wolfe is physically in the
memory now maybe in real life he's just
getting images of the memory as we can
see him kneeling before the statue but
because this is a video game we're given
control and able to play through it so
it's not entirely clear but what is more
important though is who the bells belong
to that being anosuke's mother and owl
the memories are sort of a point of view
of the holder that's why we don't see
the interior ministry in the first
memory as to the old lady's knowledge it
was just the bandits who raided the
estate as the ministry used the bandits
to mask their own attacks that the blame
was put on the bandits and not them
owl's bell will obviously have more of
the real story since he was present
during the attack but we still have some
more questions to answer why do we fight
owl at the end of the second memory and
what happens after this event well as
for the first question we seem to get
the information from the sculptor
according to what he said it seems that
the buddha statue was able to awaken old
memories along with the emotions and
memories the person ringing the bell had
to me the reason we fight owl is so that
wolf can come to terms with his father's
betrayal not just at the estate but
later when we get back to the present as
this charm is only found afterwards
buddha is allowing him to let out his
emotions to the only way the two know
how it's not a definitive answer but
that's what i've interpreted from this
as for our final question well we know
the answer already the aftermath of the
memory is the intro it seems that while
the plan worked owl was unsuccessful in
taking kuro maybe due to the temple
caving in or maybe because kuro managed
to escape either way owl was unable to
find him but seeing as wolf is now the
only one alive thanks to being
resurrected from the dragon's heritage
and is now next to the corpse of lady
butterfly he was framed for the attack
and thrown in jail this of course
relates to the first conversation we
hear in the intro that shinobi at the
bottom of the well we didn't shackle him
restrain him nothing
that doesn't worry anybody not at all
not only is he unarmed he has completely
lost his will to live
nothing but a coward
unworthy of our concern wolf was tossed
away in seeing as he had lost his
purpose along with his weapon they
didn't bother restraining him as it was
unnecessary so basically owl with the
assistance of the interior ministry
attacked the harada estate using the
bandits as cover to mask the truth of
the invasion so that the ministry can
get a staggering blow into ashida's
forces and owl can take the divine air
however things went wrong and owl
couldn't take him but he wasn't going to
give up that easily owl then appears
three years later in front of kuro who
just outright tells him that he wants
his divine blood wolf then arrives and
owl decides to enact the plan he
attempts to persuade wolf in joining him
by using the iron code and reminding him
that he has to obey his father's word
should he agree this will lead to the
first ending in the game but we'll save
that for later as the true choice is to
betray the code remember how i said the
presentations of these fights were
breathtaking
i can't tell you how hyped this made me
i was already hooked by the game to
begin with but this one scene had me
completely invested in the fight owl
isn't my favorite boss as that one is
specifically held for someone towards
the end but he's definitely a close
second the souls games have always tried
to add variety in their boss encounters
sometimes they have these large slow
moves as opposed to fast consistent
swings but other times they have unique
gimmicks the issue with sekiro is that
it's hard to pull this off when the
combat is based around one weapon and
one style of play but it seems that from
software wanted to try this with owl and
i think they succeeded throughout the
game we've been using our prosthetic to
assist us in fights it's incredibly
powerful and sometimes too powerful with
the introduction of owl we are now on
the receiving end of that treatment as
he throws these balls that prevent us
from healing chucks dozens of shurikens
at us and even begs for mercy at one
point just to throw a smoke bomb at our
feet he's a prick and doesn't play fair
at all but given that we've been doing
the same the whole game it's a humbling
experience to be on the receiving end of
it plus we're not on an even playing
field as we have two skilled shinobi
with an arsenal of tricks up their
sleeve which creates one of the best
fights in this game and the second
encounter with owl makes this all the
better as the harada estate is a great
level i like the idea of putting
together the story through the context
clues in conversation as it retains that
soul's formula of a cryptic story that
the player is forced to figure out my
only gripe with this level is that this
integral piece of story is completely
optional the old lady is an optional npc
so you may never find her bell charm
thankfully owls is an item the player
can't miss so they'll at least get one
part of the harada estate but the story
of this level is confusing without both
bells just like the story i don't mind
the player being forced to explore and
uncover everything on their own i just
feel that something as important as the
estate probably shouldn't have been
optional after we kill owl we can talk
to kuro and continue our duties this is
around the time where we discover the
location of the fountainhead palace as
well as curl's plan to kill himself in
order to sever his mortality but we've
already talked about that earlier the
only reason i didn't wait until now to
explain it as it would have just been
more confusing so it's around this point
in the game where we go to the
fountainhead palace and attempt to find
the divine dragon and the ever blossom
tree or if we want to take a break from
that we can also gather the items for
the other endings but before we go on
that journey we can eavesdrop on isian
and learn that not only will gonichiro
return in the future but he plans to
bring the second mortal blade this is
huge news as it's never mentioned that
there is a second blade at all i don't
want to overload you with more info
about that blade so we'll talk about it
when it's relevant at the ending but do
just remember that it does exist our
journey to the divine dragon will take
us to the meebu village where we're
required to pray in a pelican before
being picked up by a giant straw doll
who transports us to the fountainhead
palace i'll be honest with all of you i
don't got a single explanation for this
i don't know if this is something in
japanese culture but i couldn't find a
single thing it's weird and it's
probably better if we just move on and
act like that didn't just happen upon
arriving we encountered the defender of
the palace who is named the corrupted
monk her backstory is that she was among
the infested which is why she has a
centipede within her but she doesn't
seem to mind that as she is the palace's
guardian after all so immortality would
be quite fitting for someone like her
here in the fountainhead palace is those
carp-like nobles that drink the water
but there's also the okami women
sometime long ago the okami women
discovered this palace and even though
the nobles got here first and don't
appreciate visitors they were fine with
these warriors living with them as long
as they became the palace's guardians
they agreed and now the two live
together surrounded by the rejuvenating
waters as we talked about earlier tomoe
the one who trained gennichiro was
originally an okami woman as she was
able to conjure lightning similar to how
they can however this is where things
get a little confusing the tomoe served
a lore to keru think of wolf and kuro's
dynamic as the same thing as theirs
takero is kuro and tomawe is wolf just
like our current duo takeru and tomoe
were trying to sever the ties of
immortality a majority of her notes
detail their progress on the matter
these notes are actually how wolf and
curl realize that they needed the mortal
blade in order for these severance to
work properly but if we find more of her
notes we can discover more of the story
one of them reads lord takeru's coughs
are worsening still returning to the
divine realm is hopeless and i only wish
to sever the dragon's heritage and
restore his humanity so it seemed that
the two wanted to go back to the divine
realm implying that they had been there
once before on top of this information
we can also look at the lore
descriptions of the aromatic branch
which is on owl's body in the present
and the aromatic flower which is on his
body in the herata memory from what i
can gather it seems that lord taker was
of the divine lineage since tomoe was
trying to sever his ties of immortality
just like we are with kuro furthermore
lord takero possibly came from the
divine realm which would explain his
divine blood but looking over that note
it seems to apply that tomoe also came
from the divine realm but it's never
explained how that's possible once the
two left the divine realm takera would
take a branch from the ever blossom tree
as a parting gift and would eventually
plant it into ashina to create an ever
blossom tree we know this because emma
explains that lord takeru used to play
the flute where we're standing while
tomoe would dance under the ever blossom
tree however it seems that the tree
withered away despite that being
impossible and it seems it's because owl
took a branch from it possibly because
he believed this was required to obtain
immortality so the branch breaking thing
sounds really weird so allow me to
elaborate i believe that takeru took a
branch from the ever blossom tree since
it's located in the divine realm and we
know that he lived there once before he
then planted the brand from that tree to
make a smaller ever blossom tree owl
then took the branch from the smaller
ever blossom tree and then it of course
withered away so if the branch is able
to destroy a smaller tree what happened
to the big one well we can look at the
divine dragon as the full name of the
boss is the divine dragon of the ever
blossom tree when takero snapped a
branch off the ever blossom tree that
affected the divine dragon which is why
its arm is missing when we fight it
however even after all their planning it
seems that the duo failed and both died
the reason for their failure is because
they didn't have the mortal blade but we
do so we can now succeed where they
failed but we still need those dragon
tears just a reminder in case you forgot
we're fighting this dragon because we
need to obtain the divine dragon tears
as it's necessary for the severance
ritual even though there's not much in
the arena itself i really do like this
set piece and it's very gorgeous it's
truly divine as the game intended it for
it to be this fight also segues into
another positive about the game and it's
these final death blows death blows
occur when the player has a full posture
bar for bosses there are multiple death
blows that the player must do to defeat
them but when it's the last bar it
becomes a final death blow which is this
added part at the end that ties the
whole flight together i love these death
blows a lot securo's combat has always
felt stylish to me like it's a dance the
rest of the series has always been about
dodging or blocking the enemy and then
when you succeed do an attack of your
own in the beginning you might be able
to get away with this but as you get
deeper many of the fights will have you
moments away from broken posture for a
total of 5 whole minutes as if you give
the boss any time to breathe all that
momentum is gone sekuro easily has the
most intense combat in the soul series
so it makes sense that you can end your
stylish fight with a stylish finisher
you're able to breathe this sigh of
relief knowing that you finally beat the
boss and while doing so are able to
watch this incredible cinematic that
caps off the fight after defeating the
divine dragon we cut open a slit under
its eyes to extract its tears and are
now able to start the ritual except we
can't according to emma the central
forces have made it further into the
castle and are right outside the gate in
order to avoid death kuro escaped and
went to the secret passage the same one
we took in the intro emma also tells us
that lord eshin has succumbed to his
illness and has passed away honestly
before we continue i gotta respect eshin
we never talked about this but after the
fight with gyobu we'll meet with someone
named tengu this person is ishin and
judging by the corpse on the floor he
probably killed quite a few ministry
members even at his age he was so strong
that the only thing that could kill him
was old age he's got my respect for that
but now we have entered the finale and
while we should go to curl we're gonna
take a detour and return to the
dilapidated temple as the sculptor is
gone halfway through the game the temple
gets covered in these pieces of paper
called ofudas and these papers can
symbolize anything from a medium to
allow people to communicate with deities
through prayer or other things like
finding safety or finding love these
papers just like the remnant from
earlier in the video is a hint of what's
to come as we run through the
battlefield we'll come across a few
burning structures which isn't out of
the ordinary until we start seeing more
and even some claw marks around them by
interacting with the idol we teleport
and find the sculptor who has become the
demon of hatred the sculptor was a
shinobi like wolf who served under isian
and because being a shinobi means you're
surrounded by killing ishii noticed that
shura was going to take over his body
shura is basically when someone kills
for the sake of killing they don't have
a reason for doing so other than the
pleasure of taking another life fearing
that the sculptor would succumb to this
fate ishin cut off his arm forcing him
to retire from being a shinobi and
temporarily halting shura the sculptor
would also take up wood carving as we
can tell from the buddha statues as a
way for him to keep his mind busy but it
wasn't enough as the flames of hatred
were still burning inside him and it was
thanks to this war between the central
forces and oceana that caused him to
succumb to the power but because he was
able to withhold it for so long it was
an incomplete version of shura as a
completed version of shura is what wolf
could have been when we meet with owl
we're given the choice of obeying or
breaking the iron code if we obey we
join forces with owl however emma and
isian will attempt to stop us in both of
their fights they mention the word sure
and how it's consuming wolf if we manage
to defeat both emma and ishin then we
succeed and owl joins us again but it's
too late shura has already consumed
wolfe so while owl celebrates the
victory he gets stabbed the same way he
stabbed wolf he is now a complete
version of shura the sculptor was able
to control his hatred for a long time so
that demonic version was only a partial
amount of shura whereas wolff has no
intention of controlling it and it
happened immediately so this is the full
version of it we then get to hear a
short narration that states that a
massacre had occurred shortly after this
and thousands of people had died wolf
had completely lost it and this is only
the beginning as he still has the blood
of the divine dragon inside of him so
he's still immortal but even if for some
reason he did kill kuro and now doesn't
have the resurrection ability he now has
a new weapon in his arsenal when al
returned he came back with another sword
that is the other mortal blade so wolf
is possibly immortal with two mortal
blades and his prosthetic he is never
going to die but how did owl find the
second mortal blade well if we fast
forward back to where we left off when
we try to escape with kuro we find
ghanichiro again who has the black blade
in his possession meaning awol took this
from genichiro huge credit by the way
goes to zuli the witch for this as i
don't have access to a free cam mode on
the xbox but if you use the free cam
mode during the shura ending you'll
notice that the object in owl's hand
when he approaches wolf is genichiro's
head he literally killed him took the
blade and his head and then placed it
next to his dead grandfather which is
extremely gruesome and definitely in
line with the mood of the shura ending
however if we don't do that ending and
instead disobey the code then that leads
to all the events we've covered so far
which brings us back to the flower
garden against kenichiro at this point
we've faced konichiro so many times that
he isn't that hard anymore but there's
no way and egypt was going down without
a fight if we managed to kill him he'll
use the power of the black blade and
summon the sword saint there isn't much
info on the black blade but the item
description of the black scroll states
the blade's name is open gate and is
said to hold the power to open a gate to
the underworld it is through this power
that it creates life this blade and the
mortal blade are opposites to one
another one blade can make the undying
die and the other can revive those who
are dead as for the why i think it's
related to the sword saints remnant
which reads one who returns from the
great beyond does so at the peak of
their prosperity ishin coveted strength
and all manner of techniques through his
mortal struggle he wished for war until
his final hour and that is precisely
what he got this isn't the same issue
that died at the castle i think of it as
a mindless version of him who just wants
to fight going back to its name open
gate that's why genichiro slices his
neck open as it's opening a portal to
the underworlds that isha may come out
and take over kenichiro while he
sacrifices his life at this point though
the reveals and constant appearance of
genichiro might be getting annoying and
i can totally see that but i have to
disagree him showing up every time
always meant something big was about to
happen and he never disappointed plus it
once again reinforces his personality he
is willing to do anything possible to
save ashina he went from a standard
samurai to conjuring lightning to using
the black blade to then fully unleashing
its power by resurrecting isian if
that's not determination i don't know
what is honestly i can't even blame him
for this decision resurrecting isham was
a smart move as he kicked my ass for two
straight hours it takes everything you
have to beat him and i know many people
may want to discuss how you have to
fight him honorably but we have to
remember the way of the ashina the ways
of the ashina blade it's our school of
fighting but there are no hard and fast
rules you just win your battles
that alone is the most important rule of
the ashina style who cares how we beat
him as long as you win that's all that
counts genichiro took this to heart as
we can see all the different ways he's
attempted to beat us and even ishman
does this as well as he goes from a
sword to a spear to using lightning to
even using a gun at one point fighting
in literally took everything i learned
up until this point to beat him so it's
fitting that after two hours of failure
wasting all my healing on the first
phase i managed to beat him only using
two gourds there was only one move in
the last phase that caused me to heal
and it was this lightning attack that i
had mistimed besides that just about
everything else in this fight was
flawless and i couldn't have asked for a
better conclusion after isian is
finished we can now decide our ending
and on screen is the items that
correlate with each of them ending 2
only requires the dragontears this sees
us perform the immortal severance
meaning we take the mortal blade kill
kuro and fulfill his wish with no master
and no purpose wolfe becomes the new
sculptor he's in a similar situation as
the sculptor once was he has no purpose
anymore and has this burning sensation
of killing taking over his body so he
attempts to quell the pain by carving
statues we can see that emma joins us
and becomes our permanent doctor and
also gives us our arm back as she says
that we may need to give this to someone
in the future we learn when we get the
prosthetic arm that this originally
belonged to the sculptor who passed it
down to wolfe who is now going to pass
it down to someone else the souls games
have always had this theme of cycles
like the age of fire or even the
hunter's dream if we choose a specific
ending and this seems to be the same in
the future some other person will
stumble here with a cut-off arm and
wolfe will pass it down to that person
and who knows maybe wolf will become the
demon of hatred like the sculptor and
will need to be put down by that new
warrior one thing that is confirmed is
that he no longer has the power of the
divine blood thanks to kuro's death and
we know this because the white streak in
his hair has gone back to its original
color for ending 3 we need the dragon
tears and the aromatic flower which we
got from fighting owl in the herata
memory this is the other ending emma and
wolfe were looking into that involved
wolf sacrificing himself to make her
human again just like how tomoe wanted
to make takeiro human again but failed
[Music]
it's a really sad ending having to see
our protagonists die like that even
though it was a necessary sacrifice it
is still heartbreaking to see we then
get to see emma and kuro and it seems
that kuro was leaving ashina and will
live his life as he should now that he
is mortal and knows what it means to be
human he wants to live his life to the
fullest while he can our final ending
which many consider to be the true
ending of the game sees us use the
divine dragon tears and the frozen tears
which is an item we get from the divine
child of rejuvenation i'll be honest
again i can't explain what we did to get
this ending and i can't imagine someone
doing this without a guide it's like a
15-step process that requires you to
find five different items with no
indication on where they are my personal
gripes with that aside wolfe will use
the items on kuro and carry him to the
divine child who then for a lack of a
better word consumes him she ends up
becoming a cradle for the divine heir
which is something she talks about
during that 15 step process and it's why
we go to her for this ending she along
with wolf then set out to the divine
dragon's birthplace in hopes of sending
it back to where it came just like many
of the series secret endings it's very
confusing and doesn't really make a
whole lot of sense as there's little to
go off of but it's possible that through
this ritual the divine dragon now lives
inside kuro who is now inside the divine
child and can now be safely escorted
back home i'm not entirely sure if
that's what's going on but i would
assume if the dragon leaves japan then
the rejuvenating waters would go with it
returning the land back to normal i have
the same opinion on this as i do the
other game's secret endings and that's
while cool i just never felt any impact
from them as they confuse me more than
anything it's hard to appreciate
something that you don't understand so
if i had to choose an ending i'd
probably pick the purification ending
that has wolf sacrificing himself it's
sad but it feels complete one thing that
puzzles me though about these endings is
the fate of kuro emma and wolf as we
know the central forces were invading
ashina and there's no doubt that they
won as not only do they have the
strength weaponry and numbers it would
also undermine the entire story if they
failed which makes this all the more
confusing as you would think that this
group would be hunted down maybe since
they're not soldiers per se they didn't
bother fighting them but as we can see
from the destruction that was both
caused at ashina and hirata i don't
think they possess some moral compass so
your guess is as good as mine with the
endings finished though we've come to
the end of sekiro and that's something i
wish i didn't have to say just yet as
securo does not have any dlc there is
the gauntlets of strength but as for the
story related content there is nothing
this is the first time since demon souls
or one of the games didn't have a story
dlc and i find that quite upsetting
there is still tons of story that could
have been explained like the origins of
tomoe or even the central forces and it
sucks that we'll most likely never see
them again despite that though sekiro
was such a different experience compared
to the past souls games in both gameplay
and story and while things did get a
little bit complicated along the way as
a whole the story was fantastic it's got
a barrier of entry that is low enough to
where you actually understand what
you're supposed to do and why but it's
also deep enough for those that want to
know everything about the game it's able
to satisfy both crowds of players and
coming from a series where you're more
than likely going to finish a play
through without understanding a single
thing that happened that's very
impressive and definitely deserves some
recognition simply put if you're a fan
of the souls games go pick up sakura you
won't be disappointed
if you made it this far then you made it
to the outro and i hope you enjoyed the
video if you did then be sure to like
and subscribe if you're new secure was a
blast to play but we're still not done
yet we have a lot more souls content to
get through and i hope that you'll
continue to join me on this journey
through the series while you wait for
the next video be sure to check out my
story review on bloodborne as well as
any other videos that may interest you
if you haven't seen them as always thank
you to my returning viewers for coming
back and with that take care everyone
goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]